Bueno, empezando en este caso la clase número 8, vamos a determinar un proceso que debemos
trabajar anteriormente, ya creo que la anterior fecha era el 23, si más no recuerdo, no no
es este, voy a irme al otro y vamos a trabajar en base a los, a peníade, aquí está, creo
que lo que hace 6 acá, listo. Entonces lo que nos faltaba acá era enlazar a lo que es la base
de datos, mays eql o pueden utilizar postgres o como cualquier tipo de bases de datos, ya sea
eql o no eql pueden trabajar de manera aleatoria, no hay problema en ese sentido. Lo que yo voy a
hacer en principio es que si se vean, se tienen que descartar en este caso Sam,
cualquier versión les había comentado y en base yo pueden trabajar en base a la última versión,
las pasadas versiones, no hay problema, hacen clic en Sam y automáticamente acá arriba van a
poder ver lo que se descarga, ya automáticamente. Ahora, una vez que ya lo hayan tenido les había
comentado que pueden abrir Sam y netamente, ahí se está descargando así en el mío,
lo voy a parar, listo, no quiero, entonces yo estoy rehabilitando Sam y les voy a aparecer
esta interfaz, ya así, totalmente apagado y cuando ustedes se apretan la tecla start,
empieza el proceso, ya, pero en este caso lo único que me interesa más que todo es el mays eql,
no me interese la patch, ya y su puerto en este caso es el 33.06, ya eso me tengo que memorizar,
una vez que hagan eso, la otra descarga que se había comentado es que tienen que ser de
onre, cualquier tipo de que se mays eql, ya en este caso yo trabajo con el mays eql el front,
porque es muy liviano, solamente pesa 163.5 kb, así que es bastante, bastante, bastante liviano,
ya una vez que lo tengan, yo voy a habilitarlo eso, voy a colocar mays eql front de manera directa
aquí directamente, ya, ya, ya, nada más, ah, para que esto funcione, si o si, esto debe estar
clickeado en verde, ya, cuando esté en verde me iré al puerto directo, ahora esta parte también
tienen que memorizarse, dice localhost y ya que se su cuenta netamente de su computadora,
el local, ya, el host local, lo abren y automáticamente se les va a habilitar, ya, una vez
que lo habiliten ustedes, van a poder crear diferentes tipos de tablas y en este caso yo voy a
hacer una, como es una clase de programación en n8, sin tener conocimientos en programación neta,
o con frames o cualquier tipo de lengua, yo voy a hacerlo con algún tipo de inteligencia artificial,
así que me voy a habilitar lo que es una,
una nueva ID, en este caso vamos a entrar, muy incógnito, ya, voy a entrar en el mercado,
chasis, y voy a llegar a generarme una tabla, pero antes de consultar a la tabla,
yo voy a hacer el siguiente proceso, voy a tratar de activar el sistema en base a mi criterio,
a ver, me voy a acordar, entonces vuelvo en n8n y voy a recordarme qué hemos hecho,
o sea qué era el principal aspecto técnico y qué es mi empresa, o sea qué estoy vendiendo,
si mal lo recuerdo, en el anterior vídeo, tanto del de youtube como de las clases,
yo estoy trabajando en el youtube como venta de componentes o más de todo venta de
alimento para mascotas, ya, cualquier tipo de marcas, pero en acá si mal lo recuerdo,
creo que es agrícola, no, así, fertilizantes estoy vendiendo acá, vamos a hacer con lo de
fertilizantes, entonces voy a venir a mi chat y voy a decirle, créame una tabla de base de datos,
de base de datos SQL, MySQL, MySQL Front que estoy utilizando, en base a mi empresa,
que se llama Uriacilo, que vendemos, vendemos metamente productos
fertilizantes, fertilizantes, ahora, me voy a decir, créame, créame sólo una tabla,
de esos productos
con las características, características físico-químicas,
cas, analíticas, cuantitativas y cualitativas, bueno, vamos a extender mucho,
características físico-químicas, cantidad,
cantidad, pureza, pureza y en este caso que me dé la capacidad por tonelada,
listo, me genero eso, y ya está, ahí me crea la tablita, dice crear productos
fertilizantes y nada más, aquí me da otros, me está dando algunos aspectos más para insertar
datos, ya, voy a decirle que me inserte, insertar unos seis datos más de ejemplo,
listo, y hasta, ahí me inserto, productos fertilizantes se llama la tabla,
así que voy a crearme esto, hago clic, vengo acá, voy a ir a mi SQL,
voy a irme hacia acá abajo, tengo un montón de código ahí, así que voy a crearme, creando
la base de datos para mi progreso en N8,
ya, en este caso voy a crear, creando, vamos a llamarle Ferti,
mi base de datos Ferti, y esto voy a pegarlo ahí,
esta parte lo vamos a borrar que me ha generado, no me interesa mucho esta parte,
y voy a empezar a insertar datos, ya, voy a empezar a insertar datos,
una vez que inserto voy a copiarme acá, de nuevo voy a irme a mi chat, y voy a irme directamente
a estos, ya, los productos que estoy insertando, voy a abrir nuevamente esto, lo pego, y ya está,
esta parte voy a larga eliminar, no sé por qué me genera con esos
tres comillas, listo, a ver si, ya, lo primero que voy a hacer es crear esa tabla, se llama Ferti,
vengo a localhost, new, database, y voy a llamarle Ferti, listo ya he creado lo Ferti,
ahora voy a irme acá, clica acá, siempre para que esto corra, tienen que hacerle clic en la
flechita y tiene que desaparar la flechita, ya, entonces hacemos clic acá y voy a apretar este
que dice en este caso run select, o sea, vamos a correr la parte que hemos seleccionado, hago clic,
y ya está, ya, ahora algunos puntos va a ver problemas porque ahorita voy a hacer lo siguiente,
listo, ahora sí, ya, van a actualizarlo, porque hay veces se buguean, bueno en mí se buguean,
ya, por ejemplo ahí está, stop, no se percugula, ahora sí, ya, listo, una vez que hagan eso pueden
insertar sus datos, ya, ahora hay dos formas también de insertarlo, vamos a generar otra tabla más,
voy a colocar acá, voy a darles una base ya, porque hay veces la inteligencia artificial te va a
generar algunos aspectos más raros, así que para que no les dé algún tipo de problemas van a ser
esto, ya, pues voy a pasar esto, a lo que es la mensajera de mit y van a decir que les hay los
géneres y mirar esta tabla con esa estructura, voy a decirle, mejora y reestructura en base a este
criterio, listo, ahora sí, voy a crear, esto los voy a pasar, ya, esto está mejor elaborado que el
otro, hay que esperar un poco hasta que lo haga totalmente, ya, ahora sí crea, creamos un cachomás
y listo, voy a copiar todo esto y voy a irme acá, esto lo voy a borrar para que no tengamos problemas,
ahí, ahora sí, vengo acá, ahora lo voy a, solamente esta parte, solamente esta parte ejecutenlo,
siempre tocando esta parte, ahora sí, ahí tiene que creárselos, ahora si es que se le buguea
o algo, unas cositas, ves el mío de esta obvianza porque tengo un montón de, ahorita, cosas abiertas,
así que lo voy a reiniciar esta parte, estoy pasando por secuazo, usted es el código al mit,
listo, hago una prueba de eso, tenemos ustedes, les voy a correr normal porque yo tengo un montón
de dependencias que me genera, ya les he pasado, ya, vayan haciendo lo que por ahí, voy a reiniciar
esta cosa, para no tener problemas, listo, ya, ahora sí, listo, voy a abrirlo y vamos a hacerlo de nuevo,
ojalá, ahí hasta, listo, entonces ya se me ha creado, así se va a crear
y ahora voy a insertar los datos, a veces se va a comportar así, esto porque tengo un montón
de cositas, así que lo voy a reiniciar de nuevo, si es posible, esa parte no se preocupa,
no va a pasar eso porque no tienen dependencias, ya, así que normal, ya, una vez que tengan eso,
así van a insertar la parte de los datos, o sea, estos que estoy acá, insertar en productos,
tanto, tanto, todos estos datos que creo que hay un inserte, ya, ustedes pueden trabajar en base a
su criterio que están manejando, ya, ahí voy a clickear, ahí listo, ya está, ya, ahora sí,
voy a esperar ahí porque el mío se va a tardar un buen rato porque estoy abriendo varios sistemas
internos que tengo, ya, nada más, una vez que tengan eso, voy a pasar a lo siguiente,
ya, hacen clic acá, doble vez,
y van a hacer lo siguiente, a ver, aquí dice MySQL account, ya, van a crear una nueva credencial,
se crean una nueva credencial y aquí van a colocar los siguientes datos que los voy a indicar,
ahora, voy a abrir en este caso, voy a pasar unos códigos que ahorita, directamente al sistema
para que no tengan problemas, donde los tenía, los capítulos tenían, ya, voy a pasar a lo siguiente,
en la parte, abránse otro, otro CMD y les voy a indicar que van a pegarlo y que van a elaborar
en ese sistema, ya, voy a ver en qué puerto está corriendo lo que es el MySQL para que no tenga
un problema en ese futuro, ya, así que voy a venir acá, voy a abrir MatrosMD y voy a hacer lo
siguiente, ya, ahí tengo, ya, en este caso, ¿podemos trabajar con algún puerto interno?
A ver, ¿qué hacemos para no complicarlos un poquito? Ya,
haremos lo siguiente, entonces, les voy a pasar un código secreto para que puedan editarlo,
a ver, van a colocar esto, ya, lo estoy pasando su armit,
colóquenlo y peguenlo ahí, acá, directo, entran, si no les reconocen lo vamos a volver a
volvirlos a iniciar, ya, pero este, este codíquete que lo estoy colocando acá, lo van a pegar acá,
en vez de lo caljos lo van a pegar ahí, ya, con ese está corriendo ahorita su sistema interno,
ya, desde su MySQL, siempre, siempre cuando están trabajando con esto, si están trabajando con
otro, no les va a generar, ya, netamente, con MySQL, como hemos trabajado anteriormente,
cuando se vamos a trabajar, ya, una vez que tengan eso, podemos también trabajar de la
siguiente manera, ahora, uno es esto, aquí la base de datos tienen que llamar a que tal,
cuando están creando acá, por ejemplo, le he llamado Ferti, pueden colocarle Ferti, acá,
Ferti, el usuario sí es MySQL, pero en este caso, lo voy a colocar root, root, password,
yo no lo coloco, cuando ustedes se instalan lo que es MySQL, él se les génera, les pide que creen
un password más, pero yo lo dejo en blanco, el puerto tiene que coincidir con este de acá,
cuando voy a volver a cerrar y van a ver el puertito, aquí está el SAM, ¿no? Aquí está el
SAM, aquí está el 33.06, si nos damos cuenta es el mismo, ya, ese tiene que coincidir,
voy a abrir de nuevo mi MySQL, y listo, ya, ya está, entonces, una vez que tengan ese proceso,
no sé por qué me está generando tantos problemas, mi base de datos, voy a pasar a lo siguiente,
van a entrar directamente ahora la parte de ejecución, que es esta parte,
ya, voy a detectar esto, normal, y listo, lo voy a hacer a Runk Hatch antes de guardarlo,
la osnamos, lo voy a colocar y vamos a ejecutar lo siguiente, en esta parte, vuelva a hacer
alusión a esto, hacen doble clic, ya que tiene que ver mucho con la parte de qué es lo que van a
hacer con sus proyectos, ¿a qué más refiero con eso? Generalmente, cuando ustedes van a
seleccionar un proceso, ya, ya han creado su cuenta, ya, uno, dos, vamos a testearlo con
las herramientas de manera automática, ya, voy a colocar set automáticamente, y en la operación
hay varias operaciones, generalmente, dentro de bases de datos, se hacen los delits, sinceros,
selectos, update, en este caso, ¿y cómo quiero que yo trabaje esta ida? Quiero que la ida vaya
entrando tanto a mis APIs que hemos hecho anterior que lo sé, como quiero que entre a mi base de
datos que busquen la base de datos, lo que me pide el cliente, por ejemplo, en aquí, en esta pasada,
puedo tener, no sé, la pureza de mis productos, pues puede estar ahí, entonces, va a entrar aquí,
va a buscar, lo va a encontrar, lo va a jalar, lo va a ordenar, lo va a crear la respuesta más
en lo cuente posible, y lo va a enviar a mi correo. Ahora, eso es cuando yo utilizo en este caso,
select, y a este, ahora cuando hago inserción, es lo inverso, yo voy a meter datos a mi base de
datos, ya, por ejemplo, si yo quiero, en este caso, hacer una encuesta, o quiero obtener los datos de
mi cliente y luego bombardar con promoción, y han visto la venda en whatsapp o en los cursos correos,
siempre llega promoción y promoción, a pesar que nunca se han inscrito, pero han hecho un click,
y ya listo, ya, automáticamente les va a mandarlo sus promociones, propagandas cada día,
y ya ves, da flojera, no veo, les inunda sus correos, o les inunda sus, incluso sus webhooks de su
youtube, de algún vídeo que está en viento en TikTok, o no sé. Entonces eso pasa, yo voy a colocar select,
y ahora, una vez que colocamos el select, voy a empezar a hacer lo siguiente, voy a ahora ver lo
siguiente, voy a ver si se ha creado mis productos, si nos voy a volver a ejecutarlos,
nos voy a tener que borrar de nuevo, porque se me está volviendo el sistema, pero ustedes normales
va a dar, tienen que darles de manera natural ustedes, y yo tengo un montón de cosas que chocan,
ahora si ven, voy a tener que eliminar esto, voy a eliminar esto, voy a calerme otro, ya,
ustedes vayan haciéndolo mientras tanto, voy a volver a ejecutarlo yo,
ya, así que en el database, voy a colocar el refertil, y se ha antes, listo, voy a hacerlo a manos,
si no, para que no me molesten, voy a tratar de ser en, a manos, si no, sin ías, es mucho más fácil
que hacerlo con ías, pero, vamos a trabajar, listo, ya lo tengo seleccionado ahí, y lo ejecuto,
ya está, ahora voy a ejecutar esta cosa, voy a venir acá y voy a ejecutarlo nuevamente,
ya, y listo, ya está, ya se me ha creado todo esto, ya, eso son los dos que se me ha creado,
ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente, como ya sé que todos mis daditos se están creados,
voy a conectarlo a esto, ya, así que para esa parte de conexión, voy a trabajar de la
siguiente manera, ya, vuelvo acá, se le que está, lo voy a cerrar un rato, voy a irme directamente
acá, ya settings, y voy a hacer unos parámetros más, voy a añadir nuevamente una credencia,
y aquí les vuelvo a repetir, pueden colocar la hora y el que les sea pasado, si no les funcionaban
a que le acercen 127.0.0.1, que es la más lógica que manejame, es cuál, aquí van a colocar su nombre
de basats, fertilizantes, que es el mío, fertilizante, fertilizante, le he puesto,
fertilizante, singular, fertilizante, listo, usuario, en este caso van a colocar el root,
ya, y obviamente a las demás partes lo dejan tarcual como está, y tratan de
guardarlo, listo, ya se ha conectado, satisfactoriamente, eso les tendría que salir a ustedes,
ya, lo voy a cerrar esto, como ya está conectado, esto pueden cerrarlo y volverlo a actualizar,
no hay problema, pero les tiene que aparecer aquí el nombre de su tabla, o sea, si el psicólogo
que seleccionó la tabla tendría que aparecerles a ustedes, productos fertilizantes, porque es la tabla
dentro de mi base de datos que se llama fertilizante, vengo y fíjense, aparece, producto fertilizante,
algo clic, listo, acá por ejemplo, cuando me habilite todo esto me dices, return all, o sea,
que me retone todo lo que hago, por ejemplo, si mi tabla en este caso tiene más de un millón de
datos, aquí dice que solamente voy a analizar 50, ustedes pueden colocar esto, o todo, de canto,
ya, pero como en el mío ahorita son pocos datos, voy a colocarlo ahí nomás para no hacerle pensar
mucho a la IA, ahora aquí hay otros puntos, ya, aquí podemos, el AND se dice solamente cuando
seamos condicionales específicas, en el mundo de programación de bases de datos, hay lo que son
intersecciones, uniones de datos, entonces para ellos utiliza, o sea, podemos mezclar más tablas,
se llama consultas, así que esa parte no lo voy a manejar directamente ahí y no lo voy a ejecutar,
lo voy a dejar ahí, ya, como ya está conectado, no me interesa mucho, ah, pero algo más, para que la
IA sepa dónde tiene que buscar, porque esto se llama, mi API en este caso se llama lista de
productos, aquí se llama lista de preventistas, este debería de decir que un nombrecito que a mí
realmente sea bastante funcional y predominante en mi tabla, puedo colocar nombre de producto, sí,
ya lo tengo, pero puedo colocar qué categorías, quizás nitrogenados, compuestos potásicos,
osfatados, etcétera, la pureza también, ah, voy a puedo colocarlo acá, categoría, hago doble clic,
y voy a llamar la categoría, listo, eso lo voy a llamar, ahora aquí algunas cositas más pueden
aumentar, pero mientras tanto, no, ya voy a sorrolarlo, este es mi tabla de categoría, que es lo que
voy a hacer yo, voy a irme acá a message a mother y voy a mejorar mi prompt, ya, un system,
hago clic y voy a hacer lo siguiente, otro, otro prompt lo voy a añadir acá, si solicitan,
voy a colocar, si solicitan categorías, categorías y pureza del producto,
producto que acceda, volve a acceder, acceder a la base de datos
en categorías, categoría o categoría, listo, listo, ya está, lo cierro, puedo hacer más específico,
no hay problema, ya, pero siempre es bueno trabajar de un formato más regular, lo cierro ahí y
directamente ahora podemos ejecutar nuestro workflow, pero antes de eso voy a habilitar mi email,
ya, voy a venir acá, listo, no me acuerdo con el nombre de mi email, así que en base a eso voy a
tratar de trabajar, listo, entonces vengo acá y me voy a copiar esto, ya que yo soy el usuario,
voy a enviarme, a ver, empezaremos, ya voy a colocar, me llamo mil, dan, blanco, y me voy a pegar ese,
celular me voy a inventar el mío, listo, mensaje, quiero saber, quisiera saber si tienen productos
para mi cosecha, no sé, de maíz, ya, qué fertilizantes tienen, tienen cuál es la categoría,
categoría y la júrieza, listo lo envío, voy a empezar a pensar y debería de acceder a productos y
a categoría, ya he ingresado, ahora me voy a enviar a mi email, esta parte no sé si lo he
sacado su, su token, no lo acuerdo, que elimino, ojalá que sea el válido, si os voy a tener que
autenticarme de nuevo una credencia, porque anterior estaba dando una clase y le he eliminado,
pero esperaremos al principio, piensa bastante porque tiene que estructurar todo en base a las
nuevas alas que estoy dando, ya, así que esperaremos un rato,
y mi token no sé si le ha actualizado, ya esperemos que si me da error, es que porque
prevo mi otro token, ya lo voy a modificar entonces a mis 6 y listo, de nuevo voy a ejecutar,
antes ustedes no les habéis tocado, déjame un cachorro y no os habéis tocado,
ya quiero saber qué plantas y por eso, ven esto más rápido,
ahora sí ojalá porque mi token está, creo que lo he modificado, no me acuerdo, vences más
rápido ahora, pero espero que no se me haces valida,
un ya, esperemos que sí, si nos ve, tiene que volver a octo al San mi credencial,
no sé con cuál le he guardado, así que voy a tratar de recordar,
por eso es bueno, como se ve comentando en principio, todos sus datos guardan siempre en su
blog de notas, ya ya me he enviado, por suerte funcionará mi credencial, ese nuevo
y ahora voy a irme acá, voy a actualizar,
y listo me he llegado,
voy a tratar de actualizar esto, fíjense, me da, tengo estos productos,
oria, premio, 99.5%, todos los datos y si nos damos cuenta, si esto lo comparo con esto, fíjense,
es idem, uria, npk, sulfato de amonio, cloruro de potasio, fosfato de diamónico, humus,
liquido orgánico y el precio incluso es igual, entre los 90 y 600 bolivianos, etcétera,
etcétera, entonces ahí pueden ver que para datos más complejos pueden utilizar directamente,
ustedes ya vas a hacer de datos, ya, esos, listo, con esto estaríamos terminando esta etapa,
antes de pasar a inteligencia artificiales locales, nos falta el webbook,
esto lo voy a dejar para la siguiente clase, porque no es tan complicado, porque tengo que
enseñarles antes algunas cosas para programar antes de aplicar a webbooks, vamos a ver nuestras
fechas, ya, voy a dejar de grabar un mocacho, en este caso, es continuando con las clases,
voy a proceder a la parte de hacer un modelo local, para el parte del modelo local voy a trabajar de
manera un poquito interesante de lo cual ya se había hablado en clases anteriores en base a lo
siguiente, pueden descansar lo que les había comentado, o llama, ya, en este caso voy a colocar
olama.com, hay otros modelos, no es necesario que siempre maneja, no llame, lo que voy a hacer es
generic, es decir, que para cualquier modelo les va a servir igual, la, tiene el mismo trabajo,
yo, se os voy a tratar de ahora traducir acá, aquí modelos docs y precios, voy a irme a
documentaciones, netamente, dentro de documentaciones van a dar las llamitas, ¿no? Para las llamitas,
cada llamita trabaja como una gente, cada llamita puede albergar más de tres modelos internos y
puede trabajar con 20, 30 agentes, o sea, es como tener 30 ías trabajando para mí, que es lo malo,
los recursos los va a pedir, los va a bugiar el sistema, así que prefiero que trabajen con
procesos más adaptativos, ¿sí? vienen acá y van directamente a dolan o llama y aquí les va
de general, o que es Windows, Linux, Mac, ya o pueden instalar de manera con su PowerShell,
¿qué significa eso? Si yo vengo acá o con CMD, ahora hay otro para los que no son programadores,
hay otro aspecto principal, aparte del CMD, o sea, del comando, del consola, se llama PowerShell,
ya pueden también ejecutar con eso, algunas personas en sus compos no les detecta CMD,
no sé por qué, en mis alumnos saben tener un montón de problemas y el último saben descargarse
PowerShell nomás y saben trabajar, o viceversa, alumnos no les usan a PowerShell y a veces
usan a CMD, o sea, siempre es una de dos, ya, hay muchas características interesantes de una
cómpuca que establece para que funcione a ambos y a los que les da super, pero a los que hay veces
sus computadores son, no sé, generaciones son un poquito más atrás, si tienen dificultades,
ya, eso, puede descargar esto, yo voy a seguir trabajando con CMD para no complicar,
ya, pero a qué me voy con eso, en PowerShell lo pegan esto, hacen clic y se va a descargar y se
va a automáticamente se va a instalar, pero si no quieren trabajar así, quieren trabajarlo de
manera visual, de manera gráfica, vienen acá, acá, directamente lo descargan, ya, y doblan y van
a colocar que ahora vamos a ver cuánto pesa ahora, antes pesaba más de 250, medio giga,
pero bueno, a ver, vamos a esperar, esto va a eliminar y vamos a esperar,
satarda a veces, ya hay veces que apretar tres veces, así que eso tengan paciencia,
ya, por el caso dice Windows 10 o later, ya, así que esa parte, cuidado, listo, ah, aquí está,
dos gigas, ya, esos dos gigas tienen que descargarse, una vez que se descarguen,
lo ejecutan, yes, yes, yes, todo lo publican, sí, sí, sí, y hasta instalado, no tienen que
hacer ningún tipo de aspectos técnicos más para esa parte, una vez que hagan eso, reciban a venir
acá a Models y les había comentado clases pasadas que pueden descargarse diferentes
tipos de modelos, ya, las que tienen 26B, 122B, 48B, o sea, que sean superiores a 10B,
si eso significa que son 10 billones de parámetros ya entrenados, por ese caso. Ahora,
si encuentran un 26B, 48B, 35B, que pese 4 gigas o 5 gigas, genial, elíjense esa,
pero, por ejemplo, ya voy a elegir el Gema 4, que tiene 10.8 millones de Pulse,
o sea, descargas, voy a venir acá, voy a ver cuánto pese ese modelo, miren, aquí está,
9.6 gigas, este es el Gema 4, 31B, 31 billones de parámetros, miren, 20 gigas,
si ustedes quieren entender modelos mucho más trabajados, pre-entrenados y que se adapten
a cualquier tipo de preguntas, yo les recomiendo que se instale el Gema 4, 31B, otro que le hace el
pare, digamos, es este, el DeepSync hay uno que es este igual, que puede entrar al igual,
hay otro, el Gela M0 con Gela M4, aquí está, el Nemotron, el Nemotron ya es el pare,
ya podemos ver cuánto pese, miren, 30 billones, 24 gigas, si quieren eso, pero uno bueno es el
Nemotron, este, el Nano 4B es bueno, no se bogea, pero como les había comentado, no es bueno tener
varios modelos internos, si es que no tienen un buen almacenamiento y una buena GPU y una buena RAM,
así que yo les recomiendo que trabajen siempre con los modelos que son Mistral, los Mistral o
los Queen, o sea que tengan la parábrica principal Mistral o que tengan los Queen,
ya cualquiera de esos términos no tarda mucho, trabaja de manera correcta y es adaptable a
cualquier tipo de proyectos, en mi caso yo tengo solamente uno, porque mi compu está a punto de
morir, así que voy a buscar mi Mistral y este va a descargarse, tiene 7 billones, es buen número
y trabaja bien, bastante bien debido a ello y aquí tiene 4.4 gigas pese, ya si yo lo tengo,
ahora una vez que generan eso, voy a empezar a clicarse los acá, les voy a dar las, les voy a
pasar los prongs correspondientes para ello, entonces volviendo al asunto y al meollo del asunto,
vamos a hacer lo siguiente, una vez que esto lo instalan y ahora hacen clic y van a colocar lo siguiente,
o llama run Mistral, lo colocan y se va a auto descargar el modelo Mistral, no es necesario
descargar algo visual, ya y para llamarlo eso llama run Mistral o llama Mistral nada más,
y los descargo doble Mistral también, no hay problema, para esta parte si eligen otros
modelos, siempre ayudense con IAS para que se como si instala tal model y les va a ayudar,
pero siempre cuando le origen diferentes modelos, aquí mismo están sus chanchullos que tienen que
hacer sus guías, todos lo que tienen que trabajar, ya una vez que lo instaran esos dos,
suumen, cuánto tienen, 4.4 gigas más 2 gigas, 6.47 gigas almacenense muy aparte para un modelo,
ya el oleámalo tienen que descargarlo más veces, solamente los modelos y quieren más modelos,
una vez que hacen eso voy a habilitarme yo esto, el CMD, voy a borrar y voy a hacer lo siguiente,
voy a colocar o llama, list, cuando ya han instalado ambos, bueno colocar eso y los va a decir qué
modelo están instalado, ven 4.4 gigas, he instalado hace tres meses atrás, una vez que hagan eso,
van a hacer lo siguiente, van a colocar core, HTTP, si no me acuerdo muy bien, mi porto era 127,
1.0.0.1, 2.0, este modelo o llama siempre corre en este puerto, en 11.434, eso nos va a funcionar
a todos, no hay problema, una vez que hagan click, su oleama va a empezar a correr con su modelo,
list, ya dice oleama y running, está corriendo, una vez que tengan esto ahí lo van a minimizar,
lo minimizan y voy a proceder a hacer el nuevo workflow, venimos a que esto se van a guardar
eso, ya lo que hemos hecho hoy día, porque lo voy a ejecutar luego con modelos internos y luego
se va a hacer con webhooks, así que voy a crear un workflow y ahí voy a empezar a hacer un modelo
nuevo, ya, estos modelos nuevos voy a trabajar de manera normal, como estamos trabajando,
voy a hacer una submissions, voy a hacer esta parte, voy a acomodarme ahí,
ahora voy a habilitarme otro, ya saben esto siempre se utiliza para capturas,
no es el edit fields, listo, lo voy a hacer mientras tanto, ya se ha conectado,
no hay lios si se conecta, para que se vea mucho más bonito, si lo pueden colocar,
o más vistoso ahí, luego necesito ahora si, todas las sillas que yo trabajé de manera local,
siempre se maneja muy adelante el HTTP requests, y se van a colocar y se va a aparecer esto,
hace un click y se va a autoconnectar, ya está, ahora voy a mandar igual un mensaje,
así que voy a colocar send messages o gmail, y dentro de gmail voy a buscar send messages,
que me envió un mensaje, get messages, send messages, listo, yo lo tengo, una vez que lo
tienen eso ya tienen todo terminado, vamos a hacer un ejemplo bastante sencillo y luego vamos a
complicarnos la vida, pero en esta parte voy a trabajar de nuevo con mi one force omission,
ahora si, acá y todo esto voy a empezar a crear, yo un proyecto,
vamos a ver, voy a mandar otro negocio, a ver que puedo vender ahora, se me acuerda,
por ejemplo aquí estamos muriendo todos, así que se me acuerde que vamos a comprar,
ya vamos a inventarnos que la empresa,
empresa, importadora, delactives, delactives, volos, planta, delactives, todo tipo,
de, delactives, voy a colocar acá, vamos a añadir uno, ustedes ahora si hagan de acá,
porque esto es bueno, no lo tienen, ahorita lo llaman, porque esta tarea va a ser para,
les voy a dar una semana para que generen un proyecto nuevo, ya y me presenten ahí,
que basta lo que va a ser local, por si caso, que quiero capturar de mi cliente, nombre completo,
que quiero que sea tipo, texto perdón está bien ahí, solamente voy a decir que sea un
valor requerido, listo voy a capturar su email, que es lo que más me interesa, su email y su celular,
email y vamos a colocarlo acá, tipo email y también que sea un atributo requerido,
luego voy a añadir otro que va a ser en este caso, su celular, celular o whatsapp,
ya y en este caso igual, que sea tipo numérico y que sea también un atributo requerido,
y lo voy a colocar en este caso, el mensaje, que mensaje quiere enviar, textarea y listo,
ya saben que en la parte última tienen productions, app en el atributo y listo,
ya está, puedo ejecutarlo, voy a colocar igual un dato verdadero de mi de mi correo,
no me acuerdo al nuevo correo de mi correo, siempre tengo en un correo de pruebas netamente para
sus proyectos, los recomiendo que mezclo, listo, listo, email, voy a pegar eso,
celular un sesenta y veintidós, solo el trecho y seis dos, que es el mío y el mensaje,
quisiera ver que productos lácteos ofrecen y en que sucursales, en que sucursales,
eso es a nivel bolivia, quiero hacer un pedido, quiero hacer un pedido para cada ciudad,
listo, lo enviamos, lo cierro y a esta parte cita, ya lo tienen, ya, solamente que acá antes antes de
empezar voy a hacer lo siguiente, esta parte lo van a dar pin de ira, ya la van a pinear,
lo digo pinear y ya está y lo dejan, cierranos así, una vez que tengan eso vamos a editar los
fields, dentro de los fields voy a tratar de trabajar de manera un poquito más natural,
como ya habíamos trabajado anteriormente, voy a hacer de manera manual, vamos a mapearlo,
yo voy a jalar esto, nombre completo, el email que es necesario para mí, necesito el celular
y necesito el mensaje correspondiente, listo, ya tenemos cuatro, una vez que tenemos cuatro,
ya pueden ejecutarlo, ahora para esta parte es un poquito complicado algunos puntos,
voy a mantenerlo mientras tanto, antes de añadir un prompt, pero puedo colocar acá,
voy a añadir un field, todavía no, vamos a ver qué ejecutaremos, vamos a ver qué vamos a crear,
vamos a crear un field, ya ahí las tiene que aparecer y listo, ya, ahora dentro de este
sistemita voy a tratar de elegir un nuevo sistema de expresión interna para no tener problemas
internos tampoco, ya, a ver qué podemos hacer acá, voy a añadirme un field,
voy a colocar prompt, este prompt siempre trata de manejarlo con mi núscula, no, no con mi núscula,
por algunas cuestiones internas que tienen, algunos modelos medio, medio especiales son así que yo
los recomiendo que coloquen, ahora dentro de string le van a dar ustedes ese prompt necesario,
ya, por ejemplo voy a colocar aquí string y voy a colocar valor, en el valor,
van a decir lo siguiente, eres un asistente de venta de productos,
productos lácteos, pueden generarse esto con ida, no hay lío, pero quiero dar algunos puntos más
específicos, ya, eres un asistente de venta de productos lácteos, dos puntos van a colocar luego,
responde de manera formal en base a tus datos con un mínimo de cinco opciones a productos derivados,
ya, y además, voy a juntar paralelamente los precios en cada sucursor a nivel Bolivia,
ya, lo voy a decir, solo tenemos las sucursoras,
el troncal,
ya, voy a decirles donde pruebas,
la paz,
y cochear,
ya está, una vez que hagan click ahí, van a colocar otros dos puntos, cada que le den un prompt,
siempre se colocan dos puntos, ya, o sea cada que cambien de parámetro o quiera andar o algo
la mayor referencia, siempre colocan dos puntos, ya, y en este caso, como está acá,
voy a colocar lo siguiente, podemos adjuntar ya lo que es el Jason Message,
aquí voy a colocar, juntarlo, aquí le hemos adjuntado el Jason,
a ver el mensaje, pero aquí le pueden volver a adjuntar eso, para que se le quede claro que
aquí va a responder, así que acá lo pueden dejar acá, y ahí, digamos, no hay lío, ya está, ya,
y listo, lo vamos a hacer ahora eso,
una vez que tengan eso, ya podemos entrar al HTTP request, ya, en el HTTP request,
voy a hacer doble click y voy a hacer lo siguiente, mi modelo en este caso puede ser get o post,
ya, yo voy a manejar de manera natural como un post, esto van a cambiar,
ya, ahora, lo que les había pasado anteriormente en el URL, aquí van a colocar, si no me acuerdo,
a ver lo que les ha pasado, era HTTP, dos puntos, vaja vaja, 127.0.0.1, 2.11434, API, vaja, generate,
listo, si es que no me, si es que estoy bien, ya, ya esta parte de la parte de la autenticación lo
colocan en, por defecto, van a adjuntar send body, y aquí le van a llamar en formato Jason,
si esta, en Jason, vamos a meter juego, en acá, specific body, van a colocar Jason y Jason,
y aquí van adjuntar algunos puntos, ya, van a abrir llaves, y voy a hacer lo siguiente,
y voy a modificar esto, van a abrir sus llaves, y dentro de las llaves, vamos a colocar el modelo,
yo tengo el modelo MISTRA, tienen que colocar tal cual es el nombre del modelo, o sea,
tal cual está acá, mi nombrecito de mi modelo es MISTRA, o sea, antes de los dos puntos,
eso tienen que colocar hoy, ya, voy a colocar entonces MISTRA, voy a colocar eso, comilla doble,
voy a colocar en este caso model, dos puntos, comilla, y voy a colocar control B, MISTRA,
voy a irme hacia abajo, voy a hacer otros de nuevo, voy a colocar prompt, prompt, el prompt que hemos
quedado hace rato, o sea, que ustedes se acuerdan, el prompt, pero en este caso,
dos puntos, y voy a colocar prompt, pero antes de eso, voy a hacer el rato en cachó, voy a ejecutar
esto, porque quiero que ese prompt se actualice acá, le ha añadido el 1, no, no ve, aquí está,
miren, se actualice el prompt, entonces vuelvo acá, y ese prompt que están viendo ahí, lo voy a
colocar entre comillas dobles también, y voy a jalarlo ahí, listo, ya, una vez que lo jalan,
de nuevo voy a agregar algo más, ah, perdón, me he salido de las comillas, voy a control X,
listo, ahora sí, bien, aquí se abre otra coma, y voy a escribir otro aspecto, voy a colocar
stream, y los streams para procesarlo, ustedes no van a cambiar en ustedes,
voy a colocar false, así que dos puntos y false, false, listo, entonces una vez que lo tengan hasta
ahí, traten de esto siempre, ordenarlo así, bonito, porque a veces medio especial resumen
unos aspectos más técnicos, y ahí cuando hay programación, es pasa eso, no es que lo estamos
haciendo por primera vez, sino siempre es así, ya, ahora una vez que tengan eso, ya podemos trabajar,
ahora aquí, a options, vamos a bajar con time, pero luego vamos a trabajar pagina, así vamos, pero hasta
lo ejecutan, y hay que esperar porque está pensando ahora nuestra I a interna,
ya, ahí va tardar, porque al principio cuando corro por primera vez, siempre tarda,
ya unos minuticos va tardar, hay que ir entrenándose, ya, ya está, no te exige successfully,
MC, ya está, entonces si lo cerramos, ya está trabajando con mi I a interna, ahora podemos
enviarle el correo, pero para esto ya saben, esto tengo, esta parte siempre tengo que capturar de
mis edit files, el email, no del otro, ahora subject, puedo colocar bienvenido, no sé, una bienvenida a mi
cliente, bienvenido a Lactios Bolivars, Lactios Bolivars, listo, ahora acá pueden añadir,
este es el mensaje, pero el mensaje va a ser mi respuesta generada por mi HttpRequest,
ya, o sea, por esta cosa, y listo, ahí puedo añadirle que el formato Httml, mejorarlo,
a ver, vamos a mejorarlo un poco, ya, voy a decir acá, voy a irme a mi I a,
a ver, quisiera, cómo sería, a ver,
ya voy a hacer esto, vamos a venir al maquillar, ya quiero decir, generame
en Httml y CSS, una respuesta
a un correo en base
para esto,
ya, que me coloca,
a ver, pueden irvolverlo bonitos, ustedes ya saben cómo hacerlo,
ya, voy a adjuntar ahora el prom, el usuario,
ya, ¿cómo me acuchó?
está, estaba acá,
esto voy a adjuntar, la,
pueden venir acá, no, voy a colocar, a ver,
mensaje,
dos puntos,
nombre,
cliente,
dos puntos y de edit files, voy a capturar el nombre,
esto lo pego y lo voy a generar acá,
adjunta esto,
ya,
ya listo,
puede ser así, pero luego lo voy a calificar así,
primero que esté acá, ya,
listo, voy a cerrarlo y voy a ejecutar,
listo, ya estoy ejecutado, voy a abrir mi,
email,
vamos a actualizarlo nuevamente,
ya me llegó,
pero no le he dado una, una temática por si acaso,
así que esta parte al principio siempre se va a salir así,
ya, tienen que esperar su modelo a que dos veces haga locura,
así les va a trabajar, pero si se dan cuenta,
ya está enviando automáticamente, ya,
y pueden darle unas tres, tres haganle a cuatro y les va a funcionar,
solamente que tienen que ya tener premodelo y tienen que darlo sin error,
algo, no esto, ya,
entonces esto
va a ser su proyecto, la siguiente clase,
algo básico con cualquier ida interna que ustedes tengan,
ya, nada más,
esta parte ya saben, no tienen que enlazarlo con su propia credencial,
que ya están acá con la misma, siempre trabajen con una,
no creen en eso como yo,
porque yo tengo un montón de cosas,
hay veces que hay que creerme varias cuentas y hacer eso,
pero así, luego vuelven a entrenarlo acá,
una vez que ganas, vuelven a entrenarlo,
hasta que les envíe, ya, y es rápido ya acá,
si se dan cuenta ya no tarda mucho,
ya, y esto por si acaso tiene que estar corriendo,
siempre,
ya, nada más,
bueno, hasta ahí vamos a llegar a la clase de chicos,
eh,
voy a secar sus asistencias,
traten de,
no os voy a dar la odiataría,
porque la tarea es eso, proyecto que me tienen que presentar la siguiente clase,
eh, voy a hacer lo siguiente,
voy a detener la grabación,